hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we're talking about the questions
to ask
during a job interview when they say do
you have any questions
you should pull out that scroll and be
like
yes actually if you have 20 minutes um
and go into it and so these are the five
questions to ask number one this is very
2021 specific but how has the pandemic
affected
this company's operations and this
specific
role one they can say oh actually
really the biggest effect was that it
had to be online now
but it can also be that they now had to
switch a lot of things up if
their business had to do a lot with
in-person interaction let's say you work
for a theme park and you're trying to be
a developer there
now the pandemic very much could have
affected
them and their day-to-day operations and
really just everyone from the top to the
bottom
this is also a great question to
understand how the company
deals with unexpected change and
extremely high
stress situations which is really funny
because that's a lot of times what
they want to know from you so we're in a
very rare opportunity where we can ask
direct questions to get a sense of how
they deal with that as well because if
you find out that they
fired 50 of the people and now they're
over here trying to hire you
meanwhile jenny over here is still
without a job
that there's something wrong there you
know what i mean and so
it's a great way to just see how the
company reacts to yeah change
and any unexpected things that your role
now has that maybe the person behind you
the person before you did not have to go
through number two
what will the first 90 days in this role
look like for me
this is great for you to just lay down
the scene of understanding what to
expect
me i get very flustered and anxious
with the not knowing with every day
being like hey
when am i supposed to do x y and z or am
i supposed to know this by now do
they expect me to be building all of
this right now
and this is a great way for you to kind
of hold them accountable
later on and say well you actually told
me the first
three months here would look like x y
and z and so that's what i'm trying to
make sure i provide for you all this
also provides you
with the opportunity to say what you
as a worker kind of needs
as support from them are you the type of
person who likes to have you know your
direct manager on standby so you can ask
questions are there channels
for mentorship are there channels for me
to ask
you know a buddy can i have a buddy that
i can ask these little
questions to like where's the kitchen
where's the copier things like that
or is it going to be very solo do you
like working solo saying something like
oh well in the first 90 days i really
like to focus on my job description
really
understanding the lay of the land really
observing everybody else and how they do
things
and so please don't be alarmed if i
you don't hear from me much it doesn't
mean i'm not
working or doesn't mean i'm struggling
it really means that i'm trying to just
take
everything in as much as possible so
it's a two-way
street of understanding what they would
expect from you
but you providing what you would need as
support and what they can expect
of you too that way when if and when the
first 90 days
comes for you both of you just have a
better idea of how
you operate number three what aspects
of the company culture would you like to
be developed
this is great because companies like to
toot from their horn
up on the rooftop up on the mountains
talking about how great their company
is and i'm not saying they're lying but
sometimes it takes that extra push extra
question of saying
yo actually but what's wrong with this
company because there's always something
wrong
in a company it doesn't mean it's a bad
company or be a bad place to work
with but you still need to know those
things so you can better prepare
yourself so that you can also make more
informed decisions
of do i actually want to work here or
not and so
saying yeah what parts of the culture
would you like to be developed
it's really code for yeah what's wrong
here like tell me
what what do i need to know and so this
is a great way for
them to see that okay you actually care
about
the other things surrounding your work
not just the job description not just
you know
the the technical things but the actual
vibe of this workspace and it forces
them
to actually be honest with you and tell
you what that
is something i like to do is once they
provide their answer
i like to ask them what efforts they're
putting in place
to get that done because if they say oh
well this sucks but
we just deal with it i don't like it and
so i like to just
to follow it up with oh that's really
interesting for you to say
are there or what are the steps being
taken to remedy those
issues and that really makes them
be held accountable for the workspace
and yeah what's going on there so it's a
great two-parter number four this kind
of goes with number two and that is
what do you anticipate will be the most
difficult
part about my transition it kind of goes
to number two of describing my first 90
days
and now yeah what do you anticipate will
be the most challenging thing for me
and this is great again for preparing
you especially if they say
oh we think you learning c plus is going
to be the most difficult part
then you can spend the next you know
week or two before you even start your
job
to learn and whatnot and just have a
nice smoother
transition into it all and this is also
great
when they check up on you once you start
working
and let's say you've been working for a
few weeks and you're really
having trouble learning c plus it's
really great to know
that they know that it was going to be a
struggle does that make sense
sometimes what's difficult for me is
feeling like shoot i don't want to say
i'm having issues because
they expect me to know this and they
expect me to be all up in here and all
of this and so i don't want to show any
type
of weakness or show x y and z so now
that you
know that they know that this is a
struggle you're less scared to bring it
up once you start working actually yeah
you're right this is a struggle
um are there any extra resources or even
bringing up in meetings and things like
that because
they are the first ones to have admitted
that
it would have been difficult for you and
then last but not least
number five is there anything about my
resume
or about our conversation here today
that
gives you any type of pause or concern i
love this question because if there
isn't it's a
opportunity for them to praise you it's
a great way to kind of
gauge how they're feeling about you they
can either say no we think you
are a great match we've loved talking
with you your
your values are very much aligned with
ours and we look forward to talking with
you
you can now kind of leave that interview
with a sense of like
okay so i think i'm okay i think i'll be
good and just be a little bit less
nervous
or they can say actually we don't like
that you've only been working for
a year and this job requires two to
three years of
experience then it gives you the
opportunity
to address these concerns and say yes i
completely understand why that would
give you pause however i just wanted
noted that although i've only been
working
for a year these are all the things i
was able to do in that short amount of
time
that i saw on your job description you
expected somebody to do
in two to three years and so i hope that
helps mitigate any concerns you have so
so it creates a great opportunity to
just be like i understand that that's an
issue
but here's why it shouldn't be or but
this is why
it actually should be a positive for you
like it shows that i'm a quick learner
it shows that
i'm driven and hardworking and all of
these things and so
they can either like i said give you
praise or
give you an opportunity to address any
concerns they have
instead of you just leaving and they are
in their mind like oh she only has a
year of experience
now it's oh yeah she actually is right
she learned really quickly and she was
able to build all this and contribute
in all of these ways that's amazing and
so this thing that was once a con for
them is now
this amazing pro and so there we have it
y'all
please subscribe please like and comment
if you like this video
it really helps my channel out a lot a
lot a lot a lot so thank you
so much for watching let me know what
questions you have
if you have questions that you've asked
in interviews or you wonder how it would
be perceived in an interview please
leave them down below i'm not
an expert but i've definitely gone
through my lot of
interviews and everything so no let me
know let's talk let's communicate
and i'll see you all later bye